when it comes to the gas prices
we're going through an incredible
transition that is taking place that God
willing when it's over will be stronger
and the world be stronger and less
reliant on fossil fuels when this is
over
President Biden's incredible transition
comment on search and gas prices may not
be sitting well with the nearly 40
million Americans traveling for the
Memorial Day Weekend the national
average price of gas sitting at 459 a
gallon and a new pole finds 95 percent
of Americans say inflation is a concern
Energy Secretary Jennifer granholm
telling Americans President is on top of
it
he's obsessed with the fact that gas
prices are so high and people are
hurting and this is a global issue so
what can he do so you can exhort the oil
and gas under industry to increase
Supply which they would do it faster so
that you can bring those prices down and
it tells us that that's why you have to
at the same time accelerate our movement
to clean energy you can walk and chew
gum you can do both
okay so let's start there judge you're a
little bit fired up today so let's let's
Channel some of that energy
um the secretary says oil and gas they
got to start producing more they all say
we would like to you guys have so
regulated us that we can't do it I don't
know where the truth is wait a minute
she's the same one who said but that I
had a magic wand remember that one I do
okay here's the bottom line they're
celebrating the fact that gas is so high
they think everybody's going to buy an
electric car they don't realize that we
can't afford electric cars senior
citizens will never be able to afford an
electric cart so they're crushing the
middle class and as far as they're
concerned it's not it's nothing for them
to worry about because they've got the
deals that you know China is now going
to make the batteries they got the
lithium from Afghanistan and we're going
to get crushed that's all I have to say
well I don't know where they think
electricity comes from because I mean
you got to think about that um Greg way
back in 2008 before President Obama
became president in my early 20s right
exactly which may be a haze so maybe you
don't remember
um it may be a little uh fuzzy for you
there but he said as a candidate that he
said yeah you can build a coal fire
power plant if you want to but my
policies are going to make you go
bankrupt and remember he also said
electricity rates would necessarily
Skyrocket under my plans so we should
not be surprised this is let them eat
cake repositioned as some kind of
altruistic sacrifice you know sure
you're going to lose your savings and
you're and you're not going to be able
to go on vacations but but in this great
transition think of your contribution to
this Great Leap Forward of course none
of them participate in the sacrifice
because they don't have to and I love
how Joe minimizes our gas pain you know
what if we did that to him and at his
age he has a lot of gas pain I was
waiting how stupid how stupid do you
have to be to believe you could cut a
population off from a primary energy
source without having a viable
consistent energy source you can't say
that about solar you can't say that
about windmills because they aren't
consistent did none of us by the I know
the anti-offs are against Alternative
Energy especially when it's nuclear but
this is nuts what oh no no you the
Democrats they're they're starting they
realize that nuclear is the only
alternative energy that's going to work
and it took him 40 Years of demeaning
this industry and and trying to close
down you know all these facilities I
think now uh they're reopening the one
in California Gavin Newsom is reopening
one I mean that's a that's a sea change
big deal I I credit Michael
schellenberger on that he's the guy
that's been pushing this he has okay so
Greg says let the meat cake well that's
that's the way they said that they're
saying that are you even listening to me
I didn't hang on your every syllable
every day is my life but I'm not sure
people can afford cake that's the
problem because okay here's a look at
what it's going to be for your picnic
this year or your cookout if you're
having one this holiday weekend beef up
14.7 hot dogs up seven percent pie it
doesn't say cake but pie is up more than
13 beer is up five percent
um Joy it's gonna be an expensive
cookout this year it is going to be an
expensive cookout
um number one if I have kick I will eat
it too so I don't want to hear anything
about what's the point that happens that
is the importance
not to just completely derail this but I
felt like after the last segment we
might need some derailing um listen one
thing I hate about this is not about how
you get to the movie theater or even how
you get to work for millions of
Americans This is how you work for
people that drive a truck for a living
for people that own a lawn maintenance
right gas goes into everything on that
trailer they're going to use on your
lawn and make 20 bucks today this is not
just about convenience it is about
livelihood and when you sit there and
say well we really wish they would they
would produce more you ran on a on a
campaign of bankrupting oil and gas
taking in investment away from them and
now you pretend that's not a factor in
this I don't care how many leases they
have a lease is only as good as the oil
underneath the ground and when this
Administration took office there was a
run on land leases because for small
little companies that's the only
collateral you have to get Investments
so you go out and lease a thousand
leases if 10 of them produce oil you're
good it's those leases that are your
collateral to get Joe billionaire to
invest in you and guess what Joe
billionaire is not going to invest in
you if there's not an atmosphere of
return on investment so that's a problem
but even beyond all that you go back to
nuclear the cleanest energy that exists
Three Mile Island was a long time ago as
a matter of fact that technology is not
what we do anymore we have Micro
reactors we have uh residential reactors
we have plans for reactors to power a
neighborhood and you know who finally
got the United States government to open
up its material and facilities for
people who have designed these the
Republicans did which I I appreciate
that I'm not blaming Democrats I'm just
saying I know the person that helped
write that piece of legislation get it
passed that's why we need to speed up
that's what we need to make happen one
of the big actors here is defense
industry defense industry lobbies every
day for nuclear technology to stay out
of the civilian sector for security
reasons so you got to hit all the
players that make this worse nuclear's
way to go I fully support nuclear myself
well you are nuclear
my legs back
we're cheering for you in that respect
okay so in the meantime while we wait
for all these things Harold to come to
fruition jpmorganism among those saying
brace yourself for six dollars a gallon
national average not just California
we're talking about Paducah Kentucky and
everywhere else in between by the end of
Summer by the by August and we've got 56
percent of people in uh Harvard Harris
poll this month say their Financial
State situation is getting steady
steadily worse and that's the highest
number that poll has ever measured
look I don't disagree with any of the
remedies that have been outlined at the
table I think Democrats and Republicans
alike Joy probably share a lot of blame
when I was in Congress Republicans were
as afraid of Three Mile Island as
Democrats were they were really there
was resistance to the storage of nuclear
now I happen to think we have to build
nuclear we have to build batteries we
have to innovate we have to drill we
have to Frack uh what the war has shown
us is the vulnerability and how we are
how we are squeezed by a person whose
country we thought was largely
Irrelevant in a global economic
conversation they have proven now to
insert themselves in the conversation in
a way that forces us all to reset how we
think not only about the moment but the
future I think in terms of the moment it
was reported last week and we talked on
the show that Chevron was in
conversation with Venezuela and their
Democrats and Republicans who were upset
about that who said how could you dare
do that now if we are serious about
trying to alleviate consumers and lower
those prices from six dollars to five to
four to three fifty to 250. then we're
going to have to make some uncomfortable
choices everyone one wants to be holier
than thou then prices will go up to six
thousand six in in the immediate frame
now I'm not one my orientation to
politics is not to blame because we can
do that there's the people are doing and
that's a fine job I want to figure out
how we get going at the moment and how
we prepare how we ensure that five years
from now or even two years from now we
don't face this challenge we're littered
with mistakes from the past I make
mistakes my colleagues make mistakes but
what do we do going forward nuclear
fracking drilling batteries and
innovating how to make cleaner products
including Plastics are part of that but
in the short term we got to get our
prices lower we got to import them they
may not like hopefully for five years
from now it does not involve I'm going
to Crazy dictators to get gas from them
I would ask that one thing well you can
but they're going to scream in my ear no
but that's okay
they screaming my ear all the time do
you know how big an electric battery is
when you get rid of an electric car I
know somebody who was in cars they say
it's as big as the bottom of the car
yeah when you get rid of the car what
are we doing with those batteries series
okay go okay thank you judge hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else